pop
et dans les mois et les messieurs le
sort rabindranath duval que j'ai le
plaisir de présenter pour la première
fois en europe grâce et à la
radio-télévision jabouille de l'émission
francis channel
le ca rabindranath duval est un des
derniers descendants des grands soirs de
l'inde
vous voyez à présent le ca rabindranath
duval en train de méditer de se
concentrer au milieu des fumées qu'est
ce que vous faites votre sérénité alors
respire la fumée de chapeau melon à 10,3
et vous êtes en transe oui en france 2
non et bien ce n'est pas le fait vous
vous voyez le sens rabindranath duval
laisse pas en train de méditer assis sur
son trépied comme la pythie d'edf n'est
ce pas et d'où venez vous votre seule
unité vient de manger
pourquoi est ce que vous me dites ça
parce que l'appétit vient en mangeant
complètement ridicule n'est ce pas je
vous demande de vous voulez vous demande
de quelle partie du monde vous voulez la
de l'aide à vous êtes c'est un loup
suisse a de bons et votre fête hindoue
oui et votre grand père
par contre c'est l'unité de quelle ville
de l'est ne venez-vous châteauroux 2
chapin
à châteauroux dans l'aisne n'est ce pas
les 3l détails très intéressants pour
sérénité et on m'avait dit tout à
l'heure que vous venez de moi
il va que je vais bientôt le civa
m'avait dit tout à l'heure que vous
venez de manger qu'est ce que vous avez
mangé ce soir les clous décrit comme
tous les fakirs il était à ces zones est
à lui pourquoi lui as connu et de la
base fondamentale et rituels de la
nourriture de tous les saints à pourquoi
est ce la base de la nourriture de tous
les saints parce que tous les heures de
nuit à
ça elle a été la chercher très loin
c'est là n'est ce pas on ne peut dire
que c'est une plaisanterie qui viennent
lorient mais ce bassin tellement dit
notre sérénité alors vous voulez vous
vous concentrez un petit peu n'est ce
pas parce que je vous trouve bien diluer
la voa mes lèvres de penser à autre
chose alors concentré vous laisse pas
penser voilà vous voyez qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que je sois et qu'une fumée
pareil mondiale reconnaît que vous
débarrasser l'afrique mais vous les
volatiles et la fumée du simple alors là
présent vous voyez bien oui qu'est ce
que vous voyez je vois d'où tu vois donc
vous avez double vue comme pas assez
l'ambiance est celle des militaires tu
me dis tu as et à ta vie ta vie oui
c'est congénitale non c'est qu'on se
trouve chaque année comme ça alors je
vous prie de vous consentez une histoire
voilà et je vais à présent je vais vous
poser quelques questions il vaut mieux
poser des bombes ajoute vous concentrer
je me trouvais en plaisantent ils
quel est le signe zodiacal monsieur là
je suis placée sous le signe zodiacal du
lion et du fox à paul ii oui quel est
son caractère impulsif et simultanées
oui et sans avenir
je suis à son avenir devant lui il aura
dans le dos à chaque fois qu'ils font
demi-tour à présent quel est le syndicat
de rased moi ça les placer sous le
triple signe bénéfiques de la vieille du
taureau et des saisies thermiques sont
servis personnages y revenir et
conjugueur prolifique à prolifique c'est
très intéressant dans l'un des enfants
oui et je veux des emails à combien pays
ça court voir avec la cour à l'étude
il voit tout il sait tout après avoir
invité voulez-vous me dire y compris le
signe zodiacal de monsieur mercurochrome
oui et dites moi et quelles sont ses
goûts monsieur niveau sportif déco
sportif c'est bien les actes de ces
l'oubli et quel est son sport favori
le sport ça lui
attention la fin le sport c'est
curieusement cyclisme apprécie bien
exaltant ce weed man je lui fais paris
et
et il peut le pratiquer sans
inconvénient ce forum
oui à condition de se méfier de coire de
certaines personnes de son entourage
estime que sa compétence dans le domaine
de la [ __ ] et risque d'exercer une
face aux influences son orientation
sentimentale qu'est-ce que vous
conseiller municipal
je lui conseille de ne pas changer de
braquet surveiller 100 kg et bien c'est
à présent je ne vous devrez je vais vous
demander quelle est la couleur des
cheveux de monsieur aubin ofer dekel
teint trois obèses noirs c'est bien les
arcs
télésat à et quel est son large entre 18
et 62 oui c'est exact est ce que vous
pouvez préciser davantage
mais pourquoi faire ça change tous les
ans 10 passes et al ahmed 68 des pizzas
la tête avec 60 de la tête ou qui s'est
pas fait sans quoi tient 82 kg sans eau
sans gaz et sans électricité s'intéresse
à vous maintenant son degré
d'instruction secondes et oui il a des
diplômes
oui je suis et du sens qui est licencié
licenciés licenciés grc qui signifie
renvoyer aux galeries lafayette et que
la future l'époque voilà vous avez un
plaisir et combien monsieur at il aidé à
32° silva fait c'est exact et poiret
est-ce qu'il a des complexes
oui oui qu'elle comblera complexe elle
complexes qui font sa vessie pour une
lanterne gallo lloris polimeri forcément
la nationalité de madame français oui
son père eskimos est sa mère est surpris
mais c'est bien évidemment et parer
votre cellulite et apprises à présent
après votre sérénité vous concentrez
vous un peu disparate
et on s'est dit qu'est ce que vous
pouvez me dire à présent
leur gardien du mode texte non
et puisque vous êtes si intelligent dit
pas d'autre dieu nous avons demandé
alors
parce que oui
rouxel du dégoût des u9 voilà une
question très importante
n'est ce pas vous les bons de mondialité
concentrez-vous bien parce que c'est
très important c'est ma dernière
expérience je veux vous terminiez qu'une
crevette geslin bouquet je vais pas
je vous trouve très élevé l'esp à allah
vous êtes concentré comme lucas fait
très bien
il est concentré aux mains mais très
douce boîte
on salue des pouvez vous dit le numéro
de la montre de monsieur
je suis très fatigué a ses limites et je
pose une question vous devez les ponts
pouvez-vous dire le numéro de la montre
de monsieur oui vous pouvez le dire oui
vous pouvez le dit oui il peut dire
c'est pas vraiment solide
mais
les sensationnels il évalue à mordre sur
l'elysée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]